für diese kinder ist der wald ein
spielplatz ein hang voller erde dient
als rutsche messer äste und zweige als
spielsachen und das obst am wegesrand
ist das zweite frühstück ein wald
nördlich von berlin
hier spielen die waldläufer wie sich der
kindergarten nennt jeden tag das ganze
jahr so genannte waldkindergärten werden
bei deutschen familien aus der stadt
immer beliebter 1 bis 6 jahre sind die
kinder als in diesem umfeld können sie
sich bestmöglich entfalten davon sind
ihre eltern überzeugt ich habe in der
stadt gewohnt und war dann relativ
schnell an meiner grenze zu sagen die
kinder dabei zu beobachten wenn sie
alles vom boden aufheben ist war alles
nicht
sie konnten nichts anfassen es war alles
irgendwie eklig dreckig zigarettenkippen
müll hundekacke ich hatte das gefühl ich
muss dauernd begrenzen und es gibt so
wenig natürlichen entwicklungsraum
irgendwie in der stadt
das konzept ist recht einfach raus ins
freie bei wind und wetter einen
stundenplan für die kinder gibt es nicht
sie sollen spielen und entdecken dürfen
so wie sie es wollen den moment lernen
sie mit werkzeugen umzugehen
andreas appel ist seit 14 jahren
kindergärtner für den körper und den
geist eines kindes sei nichts besser als
die bewegung in der natur sagt er
die absicht ist den kindern eben eine
gewisse achtsamkeit beizubringen und
dass die kinder in der lage sind das was
sie hier gelernt haben
weiterzuvermitteln anderen kindern
zusammen warum tust du den käfer tod
warum hast du die brennessel um brennt
es uns wichtig für die schnecken wenn
die sonne kommt können dies für den
blättern der schmetterlinge legt seine
eier haben der brennessel ab oder guck
mal die pflanze kannst du essen dreht
sie nicht klappt so das ist für uns
wichtig ein tag an der frischen luft ist
spannend und anstrengend
mittags geht es zurück in das
kindergarten haus pause in der kleinen
holzhütte
daneben steht eine weitere hütte im
winter wird hier oft ein feuer an
gemacht bei minusgraden bleiben die
kinder auch häufig drin plastik
spielsachen sind tabu ablenkung aber ist
im wald nicht das große problem manchmal
kommt tierische gäste vorbei es gibt
hier die schafe vom nachbarn die hier
auf dem grundstück weiden und da war der
schafbock dann tot und dann wurde der
beerdigten es gibt einfach so eine
wertschätzung für alles auch wenn die
kinder durchaus explorieren und die
toten tiere auseinandernehmen oder so
aber es gibt trotzdem einfach so ein
respekt und ich glaube dass eben aus
diesem aspekt für natur für jedes
lebewesen auch ein respekt für andere
menschen also führt so miteinander sein
und auch eine andere verantwortung für
unsere umwelt so entsteht
es ist eine behütete kindergartenzeit so
wie sie viele kinder in deutschland
erleben dürfen und wie sie vielen
anderen auf der welt vorenthalten bleibt